all right I think
got Nate Janis and Jeff Roach my friends
and former colleagues from system one
over in Venice Beach I'd like like you
all to give them a very warm welcome to
our first pi day to LA and they'll be
presenting 1d convolutional neural
networks for time series modeling so
let's kick it off thanks for the intro
Neil Neil actually built some of our
data science foundation our modeling
architecture so big big thanks to him
that we use so we're gonna do a two part
talk here I'm gonna do the first part on
the on the motivation and the
prototyping and Jeff's gonna come up and
talk about the production ization and
how we used it and how he built built
out to API for us with it
I'm Nathan Janos I'm the chief data
officer at system one I've done a lot of
ad tech and Jeff is a data scientist and
has a background epidemiology which is
cool so the big idea here is is there a
1d analog to all the cool
two-dimensional convolution stuff that
you know it's been out in the news for
the past few years one of the other sort
of overarching themes throughout this
presentation is just how Jeff and I work
together to develop this and maybe kind
of in a view of the flow that we have at
our company for developing new models so
deep learning and although all the hoop
the new wave of neural network
architectures are all the rage right now
there's a lot of focus in the visual
space for our classification obviously
but it's system one we're more
interested in time series modeling
specifically we look at things like how
do we predict the revenue per click or
the cost per click for the next click or
the next hour for marketing and AD tech
type data so you know I was looking you
know how could we apply some of this
deep learning to our problem and
no I came came across some of the
standard literature there LS TMS
recurrent neural networks these are
generally neural networks that have the
neurons have gates and multipliers and
thresholds inside of them and there
they're set up chained up in a sequence
and I tried some of that and I really
wanted to see if there was a way to you
know leverage some of these interesting
deep neural network techniques but for
our problem so I have a little bit of a
background in discrete-time and signal
processing and I was wondering can we
combine those techniques within neural
networks and you know try to try to go
at it that way you know these these
discrete time processing techniques have
been around for a long time they're used
in all kinds of things like speech
processing and radar so why not treat
our hourly data samples like one of
these signals and see if we can apply
these techniques but you know with the
idea of using neural networks to train
these filters so you know the 2d
convolution works well for image
classification is there a type of 1d
convolution that works for
timeseriesforecasting so the convolution
that you hear about for deep learning no
neural network training is it you take a
2d matrix and you apply that kernel you
multiply it on top of an image and it
kind of reduces a sample
you know there's pooling and you put
together complicated architecture of
these things and so I mean you know I
asked myself what's the analog in one
dimension and there's actually something
that's called a convolution it's a
little bit different than that to
decomposition it's used in a lot of the
deep learning it's a type of integration
where you take two functions you flip
one in time and you integrate it and
slide it along and this is a graphic I
took from Wikipedia on sort of a how
that looks and then here if you're
interested
formulation on the right hand side we're
gonna be using the bottom one there
which is the discrete time you know we
have discrete samples we're dealing with
our hourly samples so the big basic
architecture we're going to work with
here we have an input signal the Y of T
it's the time series we have these
hidden layers each hidden hidden layer
and our network is a convolution layer
so it has an input and it convolve x' it
with a set of weights so you can just
think of the input as a vector and the
weights is a vector it outputs that
convolution it pulls it and in my
prototype case I did all 2x pooling so
if a time signal time series comes in
with length 24 the pool is length 12 we
apply the rayleigh function on it and
you have another hidden layer at the end
of all this there's a regression layer
that's you know this version of the
classification and all it's trying to do
is predict what is the you know what's
the next value and the time series going
to be so here's a example of this is
sort of the picture we'll be working
with for the rest of the the talk here
it's a parametrized version of this and
so in here you can specify the way I did
the prototype you can specify any number
of layers and in this case there's two
and in each layer there's a number of
filters in this case there's six across
and the way that I hard-coded it was it
if you specify a length six there's
going to be six filters going from
length 1 length 2 3 up to length 6 and I
did that because I know from the DSP
sort of world that there are standard
convolutional filters that are you know
usually smaller that do things like edge
detection and that's really what I was
trying to get at with us for the
one-dimensional case at the end there's
a regression layer that takes the output
from all this and runs a regression out
trying to predict Y of T plus 1
so this is just you know an example of
the parameter space in this previous
example counting up all the W so all the
W is here are all the weights that we're
gonna learn with with our neural network
and in that case there's there's 66
total parameters there and so here's
just some of the math there's there's
thirty filter weights I call those
filters and then there's 36 regression
weight parameters so there's a total 66
parameters in that case you'd want to
learn if you you know set the parameters
to be twenty-four filters deep three
sorry three three deep 24 wide and
running on a week of hourly data there'd
be about 1,400 parameters so a lot more
parameters to learn the parameter space
explodes as you make these things bigger
as you would expect so I had a really
complicated slide for this before about
how I did the learning but it was it was
too complicated so what I learned you
know one of the big things I learned
during this this whole process of trying
to look into this novel technique was
how hard it is to the hyper parameter
tuning and in particular you know
picking different sorts of learning
learning rate methods and the thing that
I settled on is this type of gradient
descent with restarts and the idea here
is that the learning rate starts you
know up high and it decreases and at
some point you reset it and decreases
again you reset it so this is known as
stochastic gradient descent with
restarts what I found in my example with
the data that we were working with was
that we did a lot of restarts so
sometimes you'll see three restarts I
did many many restarts I'll show you in
a second and also when I did those
restarts I didn't restart back up to the
initial learning rate I restarted up to
you know 0.95 times at an initial
learning rate sosa exponential decay
then you jump back up to a little bit
below your original learning rate
exponential decay a little bit low so
you're kind of inching down you're kind
of shaking up the system letting it
settle Andrew shaking it up
so just to give you a little description
of the type of data and the testing that
we did here we were looking at revenue
per click data on mobile devices in an
automotive category we looked at hourly
data for nine weeks 63 days of hourly
data we trained on the first eight weeks
of our hourly data and then we test it
on that last week sort of the at the out
sample and then we compared the mace of
the model to the mace of a simple model
the simple model being turns out that a
really good prediction ER for what
happens next hour is what happened last
hour so we want to we want to beat that
so we're aiming for a masive lesson 1.0
in this case that's that's good so this
is some actual training data here what
you see on the top is the learning rate
so that sort of cyan green that's the
learning rate over 10,000 iterations
through of learning you can see it about
every few hundred iterations it resets
but the idea here is it doesn't reset
all the way back up to one in this case
it resets a little bit lower so by the
end of this training you're resetting
back up to half of what you used to you
reset at the beginning on the bottom
here you see compare comparison at the
same sort of iteration intervals the
mean parameter update so this was a this
is sort of a view that I built into the
training process just to kind of see
what was going on that blue sort of
jumpy line that's the mean amount that
all the parameters were updated in that
iteration so you can see at the
beginning they're updated quite a bit
and that kind of settled down and you
see these little pulses of them being
updated and those pulses correspond with
the learning rate resets and so what
you're doing there's a lot of learning
going on at first that learning rate
goes down almost to zero then you reset
it and there's another burst to learning
and it goes down and you reset it and
you can see the you know by the timer
about halfway through around I get five
thousand iterations at this point
there's most the learning is done and
every time you reset it there's
there's not there's not much more in the
parameter updates to me that validated
that the you know that it was learning
and you know that we were able to sort
of search out this space effectively
here's a graphic of just just a sample
so you guys can kind of get an idea of
the out sample so the blue is the data
that we're trying to fit the red is the
model and you can see just kind of a
visual effect there of how well we were
doing you can see like it's very typical
very strong daily periods so that peak
is in the middle of the day in this case
this is normalized data but the peak is
almost four times the night so also in
this case the mace the mace one that I'm
comparing this point eight five so to me
that was already a success so I'm just
trying this crazy thing just kind of
inspired by the the deep learning stuff
and I see this Mesa point eight five and
I was I was pretty happy that we got at
least at this point so the the best
results I had in my prototype was
working with a network that had six
filters wide so much like that first one
you saw three deep instead of two deep
and a window at 24 hours and what we did
there is you know I took 24 hour window
and slid it across that entire sample so
from that you know eight weeks of data I
took 24 hours and slid it along hour by
hour and used those as all my training
samples and the best mace that we got
compared to the the one hour leg model
was about point eight six which is okay
so I presented this to the team you know
just some interesting research and did
you know doing some learning for myself
I realized I should probably use a GPU
framework because it was getting kind of
slow I spent I also got a good
appreciation for hyper parameter tuning
defining those parameters defining the
learning rate method and I spent most of
my time doing that actually which is
sort of like the meta learning for me I
also realized I should probably allow
for a little bit more Network
flexibility and that you know where I
enforce that there's a in every layer
there's arithmetic we increasing filters
from one to six in this case I probably
would want something more flexible there
and then it probably also be a good idea
to build this out and establish an old
network framework to better leverage
like really well coded back propagation
I rolled all my own in MATLAB
so Jeff heard this talk and he thought
it was cool and he thought he could
apply this to actually some business use
cases and so he's going to talk about
how he extended some of those
conclusions there and then also how he
did the PI torch implementation and how
it compared to another standard model
that we use so Jeff yeah so I was really
really excited to hear about the work
that Nathan was working on it's not a
really interesting different and I was
also excited about some of the
conclusions that he had come to and some
of the troubles that he had because I
was working through the fast AI course
which uses PI torch and a lot of there
were those packages accomplish a lot of
the problems that Nathan was running
into with hand-rolling a lot of his
stuff so with PI torch we could easily
integrate it into the GPU we could
easily test new model frameworks and any
sort of expansions that we wanted to do
it's very pythonic fast di which is
essentially a wrapper around the PI
torch framework allowed us to easily
test any kind of hyper parameters that
we wanted to to
work on and it's already got
backpropagation built in in an efficient
manner so we didn't have to worry about
again hand rolling that so the second
goal essentially was to see if there was
any kind of improvements we could make
on his current architecture and finally
like having an error rate compared to
like the the most recent data point is
great but we also have models that are
currently in production and we wanted to
see if we could build something that
could beat that we've tried many times
in the past and it's been really really
difficult the model that we currently
have been using is a tee batts model
this is a package that's an are
essentially it's a linear time series
model that captures really complex
seasonal trends to kind of give you a
graph of graphic of what it does the top
bar is the observed time series and the
model will essentially decompose it into
these seasonal trends the two on the
bottom the season one which is the third
row there is capturing daily trends and
it's really nice really sharp very clear
the second one is capturing that weekly
trends again you can see like a dips it
seems like on the weekend there's a
different behavior that happens then and
what essentially this model does is you
can add these layers up combine them and
you get back to that observed rate so
this is essentially the model that we're
trying to be so after hearing again
about some of the work that Nathan had
done I had done some additional research
trying to dig in to see is there anybody
else who's using these convolutional
neural networks in time series and I
stumbled across one paper that was using
what's called a wave net they had taken
this model structure that was used on
audio applied it to time series and
found that they had some good results
from it this is the model structure that
they were using they used one filter of
length three two layers deep this looks
pretty close to like what Nathan had
done so this is very very encouraging to
like see that someone else had found
some positive results from it and if we
look at Nathan's it's basically the
exact same thing more filters of
different lengths we compared these two
models and found that
the one that Nathan's model performs
slightly better and we think again to
the point that he raised earlier its
able to capture some of those more
complex edge cases in the time series so
we're gonna kind of collapse that back
down into like a simple model so I can
fit more stuff on this slide another
technique that Nathan had uses he passed
the most recent data point and just
bypassed it and went straight down to
the regression layer this helped improve
his model performance and I thought you
know one points great but why not use
the full 24-hour window and also just
pass through the intermediate steps all
the way down to the bottom this way we
have more features and kind of click
that you know what we're starting to do
here is a bit of feature engineering so
this is as far as I could get with this
convolutional model and the data sets
that we have at system one are highly
contextual holidays matter a lot because
behaviors differ around then end of
month cycles quarterly we would be great
if we could include some additional
context in this model so going back to
that feature engineering what we
actually did was attach this another
neural network from fast AI to create an
ensemble model that allowed us to input
that context in so we used fast day eyes
mixed input model essentially passed the
same 24-hour window along with any
context that we wanted to have this
model is a fully connected network
that's two layers deep and you can see
it outputs an additional 500 weights
down into that our regression layer and
we got some big improvements from doing
this so this is the final model that we
essentially ended up with for those of
you that like understand the stuff a
little bit better in code this is kind
of the pseudocode for how its mocked up
in PI torch
we called this model a filter net we
initialize these convolutional layers
you can see that let's see if the mouse
will show up perfect okay so we've got
these convolution layers that we
initialize up here kernel size 1
and we create the first and second of
those and then we continue on with the
rest of the kernel sizes below
initialize that context model and then
initialize the the final linear layer in
that forward propagation function which
is what's actually doing most of the
heavy lifting you'll pass in that 24
hour window and then any categorical or
continuous context variables in you'll
pass that window into that first layer
save out the intermediate pass that
intermediate into the second layer and
then save that out and you repeat this
process for all the filter links that
you've got stash all those into a an
array do the same thing for your context
model and then essentially you combine
these two into a final array that you'll
pass through that linear layer so you
can see that like in code this is
exactly what we were showing visually is
is going on so now time for the
comparisons we ran this T best model
which is we use for many of our stuff
and it had a Mase of 0.9 so it's doing
essentially like 10% better than if we'd
use the most recent data point and it
took 30 seconds for this to run which is
pretty quick Nathan's model which he
hand rolled in MATLAB on a CPU was
outperforming it with that point 86 but
it took 20 minutes for his model to
Train
this is not ideal for a production
environment so it was great that when we
ported it over to PI torch and put it on
a GPU that cost us the same amount as on
a CPU that we got the same performance
but got a huge speed increase cutting it
down to almost half the time it took to
train this model which is fantastic the
filter net which is that more complex
ensemble model gave us an additional
bump in performance at a cost of the
training time but considering that it's
still slightly faster than that T batts
model we were pretty happy with that
so this almost gave us a 10% bump in
performance by moving to this other
model so the next step is we wanted to
see like how well this model generalized
was something that it hasn't seen before
a lot of times we'll get
different traffic sources or partners
who come in and say like we've got this
new thing we want you to optimize it
it'd be great if we could at least make
an educated guess about how things were
gonna perform for them right out the
gate and to give our models some time to
train up so this comparison we
previously trained on like an automotive
category and then took that training
data and we've predicted it on the
automotive again which is what you were
two guys were seen before but then we
took that same model trained on
automotive predicted it on Finance which
it had not seen before and these were
the error rates for that we can see that
both models obviously performed worse
but the filter net still outperformed
that t bats and almost perform or
performed about the same as the t bats
did went on the automotive that it was
trained on so in that same lieu of not
really knowing a whole lot we kind of
wanted to test the limits of well how
much can it handle missing data points
so I systematically went through this
training data and replaced every nth
data point with the median which is
typically what we would do if we had
some missing data so for the two-step
which we'd essentially would fill every
other with missing values so this is
half the data is missing this is pretty
bad and you can see that the models
performed also pretty bad and worse than
if we just used the most recent data
point as it's over one as you fill in
less and less of the data points both
models continue to do better but the
takeaway that I want you guys to have
from this slide is that you can see that
the filter net percentage difference
continues to get worse and worse the
more missing values there are meaning
that it's more susceptible to data
quality so the previous data set that
we've been using was pretty clean we
also wanted to kind of test this on a
messy data set one that we've kind of
termed as a jagged data set we've got
things come traffic coming in from
different sources some of them use
certain features some of them use other
ones they're not all used by the same
traffic so it's important for us to kind
of make sure that these models work well
in the production environment
this dataset comprised of not just one
but almost are over 1300 advertising
categories hourly data we trained it on
a little over a month and then tested it
on the the following week so with this
we tested again the t bats model and it
had a mace of 0.84 and ran in 17 seconds
keep in mind that like all of these
metrics were all predicted on the same
test set regardless of what it was
trained on the filter net was trained on
that same category and it had slightly
better air but was trained in 1/4 of the
time for us is this like fantastic we
can get you know at least on par and
improved training speeds so we can put
more complex stuff in our system then I
wanted to know how well could this model
do if we included additional context
about what's going on maybe it can get
some information from other categories
and use that information to improve its
performance on that same category so I
trained the filter net on those that
full training set though it took 60
seconds it outperformed what it did on
the single category showing evidence
that it was able to share information
from other categories to improve its
predictions on a single category this
functionality is not we're not able to
do this on the current T best model for
every category we have to train a single
T best model and have to iterate over
and over again so for us this is
fantastic that we can train not only one
model for this whole dataset but it can
do so quickly and it improves the
performance overall for our predictions
finally we removed that the test
category that we've been running all
these predictions on from the training
set again as if it's never seen it
before and it had slightly worse but
close to the same air rate which is
pretty awesome that we're able to you
know the sharing is that strong finally
I was kind of curious why the the t
baths and
phil's ernight performed about the same
for this data set and was kind of
digging into like well how much training
data impacts how well this model
performs so I started reducing the
amount of training data each of these
models have and you can see that the t
bats model after we get down to 21 days
starts to kind of fall off and perform
worse it doesn't have enough data to
kind of pick up those seasonal trends
especially at the weekly data if it's
only got three weeks however the filter
net continues to perform really really
well even with shorter and shorter data
sets which is really encouraging so in
conclusion we think this model has like
a lot of great perks the performance
increase for one is like 7% over the
best thing that we're using right now
which is fantastic the training speed is
variable depending on what you're trying
to do but anywhere between 10 and 300%
the other thing you can do with these PI
torch models is save out pre-trained
ones and further increase the training
speed when you're showing it to some new
data we can also include context which
is fantastic ours is heavily laden with
context and we weren't able to do that
before it's also less sensitive to the
amount of data that you give it however
you have to keep in mind that the
quality of data regarding missing data
points is a drawback for this we also
did some additional testing between like
how well these the convolutional side of
the model and the context model played
together we found that both of them
performed pretty well but when you
combine them they both were
complementary and added an additional
benefit and outperformed them running by
themselves yeah so thank you guys for
listening and are there any questions
Nathan did you want to come back up just
in case there was any for you
yeah hello thanks for the great talk
super interesting so I had two questions
so one was did you consider doing some
more feature engineering so for example
taking like the derivative of the time
series or you know maybe like the data
point from one hour ago - the data point
from six hours ago do you think it would
be help help to do some feature
engineering - for the input and then the
second question is did you learn
anything interesting by examining the
weights that were the result of the
training so for example maybe you
learned that you know the data points
from one in two hours ago where like 10
times more important and though then the
data points from a tenon and 11 hours
ago did you learn anything interesting
like that yeah I'll handle the first one
and then I'll pass the second went on to
Nathan so for the first one we we tried
to keep it somewhat simple as we could
just trying to reduce the complexity
when we're doing this testing also to
kind of at least give somewhat of a fair
compare or comparison between these two
models so we included just the hour day
of week and then the days of the month
which we kind of assumed that the t bats
model was pulling from those seasonal
graphs so know that that would be a good
idea though and probably something that
we should use yeah I didn't talk about
this all but my very first attempt was
to do some pretty heavy feature
engineering both the differential stuff
and adding in like aggregation and what
my idea was and this didn't work very
well was to turn the one-dimensional
signals into two-dimensional signals by
actually if you think of a matrix it's a
vector and then maybe shifting at one or
aggregating one in creating an actual
two-dimensional version and putting that
into a traditional deep you know
convolutional neural network didn't work
very well it's better to explain on the
whiteboard if you want later so we yeah
so in in the prototype
that we showed we didn't do a lot of
feature engineering for the filters I
was very interested in that too I wanted
to see if they look like something cool
like those cool
wavy kinds of filters you see from the
the 2d so these are some actual filters
so again the filters are vectors and
they're plotted across here I mean you
can take away what you want from that
but it's interesting you know one of
these zeros out the sort of fifth one
across so this is an actual set of learn
filters from that network that you saw
that performed well and you know I don't
know if some of these are our edge edge
detecting but you can kind of do your
own take away that's what they actually
looked like thank you
so what was the data you were using to
fit here it was a revenue per click data
for an automotive category okay and
another question I had was were you
predicting like a week's worth of data
or just like the next hour just the next
hour the way we generally do that
obviously it looked pretty good right so
the way we generally do any kind of
fitting is we try to compare it to you
know actually what can we do in
production so we're gonna do the best
we're gonna you know do the best thing
we can in production so in production
it's a little more complicated because
we usually don't have everything up to
the last hour we have everything up to
about four hours ago so we didn't want
to get into that nuance but we we
compared it against a real life
situation and that's oh yeah we used
everything up to the last hour and tried
to just predict the next hour rolling
across yeah
all right thanks it was very interesting
idea that you have that train these
filters and then to use the deep
learning technique combined with it I
wanted to know you looked at these LS
teams in the first slide you mentioned
them has anybody tried to use them to
predict you know them in a production
environment the other standard
techniques yes
yeah I'm sure people have tried them I I
looked at some of them they performed
okay so you know they would work I just
I wanted to try something new I had I
had an itch I wanted to scratch his you
know to see if this stuff would work but
you're talking about like the law long
short-term memory type models yeah I I
did run some of those and they they work
okay as well I probably you know in my
memory probably not as well as the T
bats but they they can work as well okay
thanks
if you're doing multiple time series at
once could you look at that as like in
n-dimensional a convolutional neural net
like rather than scoping it down to one
dimensions it's just it becomes a
picture of many dimensions yeah we
probably could both touch on this but we
didn't want there to be like a too much
interaction and the the convolution if
you have multiple dimensions in that
convolutional filter you're pulling from
things above and below and we didn't
want there to be a whole lot of overlap
between it's kind of like you have to
make decisions about what you're wanting
to do that do you use yesterday's or
last week's 24-hour yesterday's to
overlap these things and those can
create different filters in themselves
so sticking with the 1d like at least
eliminated that complexity that might be
a cool Avenue to check out and see how
that works out it might do even better
but we essentially when we did the whole
1,300 categories we ran it and batch so
it is looking at everything and like a
matrix but there's still somewhat
separate I don't know if this also helps
answer there probably is a better way to
pack some of this into a matrix
multiplication and I think the closest
we got to that is some using some of the
batch processing with PI torch
other questions
oh good great thank you guys appreciate
it thank you very much
[Applause]